I'm going to start with a story.
In 1730, in India,
the king of Jodhpur
wanted to build a new palace,
and he needed a large number
of trees to be cut.
Alarmed at hearing this,
a group of local environmental activists
went to protect the trees
by throwing their arms around them.
We could consider them
the first-ever tree huggers.
Now, while this story
might be known to many of us,
what's often less known
is what motivated these activists.
They came from the Bishnoi community,
a Hindu lineage founded
on 29 principles of environmental care.
This is just one of so many
amazing examples,
throughout the world,
of religious communities stepping up
to protect the environment
through addressing climate change,
restoring ecosystems
and protecting biodiversity.
And I've had the honor and the privilege
of working with many such groups
in different parts of the world
for environmental action.
But before I did that,
I actually was living in India,
where I spent time in a Hindu ashram
on the banks of the sacred river Ganges,
where I was studying Hindu spirituality
and how the teachings of the Bhagavad Gita
could be applied to contemporary
concerns in the world.
And it was this orientation
of an engaged religion and spirituality
that brought me
to the climate movement in 2010.
And since then, I think like many of us,
I have experienced the highs and the lows
as we've campaigned and advocated
to keep the global temperature
increase to 1.5 degrees.
And I don't know about you,
but I think right now,
it can feel like it's a difficult time
to be working on climate change.
Sometimes, things just don't seem
to be moving as quickly as we would like.
And more often than not, unfortunately,
we might be feeling scared or stuck,
hopeless or maybe even burnt out.
Coming from the faith sector,
I've always been interested in other ideas
that are rooted in religion
and spirituality
that can support the broader
environmental movement.
I started looking into the history
of religious and spiritual groups,
and started thinking that they could be
some of the most enduring social movements
in the history of the world.
They've been able to survive
through multiple generations,
adapt to changing situations,
reform and revive themselves when needed.
They've even inspired the leaders
of some of the most iconic
social movements in recent history,
such as Mahatma Gandhi
and Martin Luther King Jr.
That's why I was really happy
when a friend of mine,
who was writing a book
about Hindu approaches to pastoral care,
asked me to contribute a chapter.
Using my previous background
as a university chaplain,
I developed a framework
that I thought could help people
suffering from climate trauma.
And as I went around
sharing this framework with people
from different backgrounds,
they told me that it really
resonated with them.
The framework, although initially
built for climate trauma,
I think can really help with something
I believe we need now
in the climate movement:
building resiliency and keeping momentum.
There are three core interconnected
parts to this framework
that are drawn from across a variety
of religious and spiritual traditions.
I'm excited to share that with you,
and I'm going to use the Sanskrit words
to explain the different aspects
of the framework.
We begin with "sangha,"
nourishing and uplifting community,
where people come together
to support one another
and reaffirm social ties.
This can happen weekly, monthly,
or at different times of the year.
So, for example, my Christian friends,
they go to church on a Sunday.
My Muslim friends
go to prayer on a Friday,
and my Hindu friends,
they will gather at major
festivals, such as Diwali.
We then have "sadhana,"
rituals and traditions that give us
a sense of belonging.
This can often be fasting
at times of the year,
or going on pilgrimage,
or retelling stories
that have been passed down
for multiple generations.
Buddhists will go on pilgrimage to Gaya,
where the Buddha found enlightenment.
Jewish families and communities
will retell the stories of their ancestors
when they gather for their holidays.
And then, we have "seva,"
purposeful action.
These groups gave guidance and teachings
for how to show up in the world,
how to care for one another
and the planet.
In the Jain tradition,
there is a focus on leading a life
based on nonviolence.
Members of the Baha'i faith
are encouraged to be anxiously concerned
with the needs of the world.
We do these things on a regular basis,
but there are two ways
that religious and spiritual groups
engage in these practices
that set them slightly apart.
The first is intention.
When religious and spiritual groups
engage in these practices,
they do them with a sense of importance,
recognize that these are core functions
of what it means to be part of that group.
Let's illustrate that with an example
from the climate movement.
Let's look at the Fridays
for Future school strike.
That was an example
where some real focused intention
yielded amazing results.
By performing a very simple activity,
not going to school on Fridays,
they were able to build a community,
a simple ritual and a purposeful action.
And by doing so, they built
resiliency amongst themselves
and motivated millions of people
around the world,
that change was possible.
Now, if we bring
these three practices together,
along with the intention,
something really magical starts to happen.
This is the second special feature
that religious and spiritual groups
bring to these practices.
It's something that provides
the ultimate grounding
and narrative and meaning
for why community, rituals
and action are important.
I call it “the big idea.”
For religious and spiritual groups,
the big idea is often a sense
of the divine, of God,
or a metaphysical
understanding of the world,
or a grand narrative
of a people throughout time.
Whatever it is, the big idea usually has
some common characteristics to it.
It's usually something
that has existed before us
and will exist after us.
The big idea is not limited
to a certain moment, time or place.
Now I'm getting some
worried looks in the audience.
Don't worry, I'm not asking all of us
to go out there and start looking for God.
But I am suggesting that we may benefit
from being part of something
bigger than ourselves,
and that can take many different forms.
For many people I meet
in the climate movement,
their big idea is being part of
and connected to nature,
and appreciating the beauty
of the natural world.
But it can also be a sense
of connection we feel to our ancestors
and the responsibility we have
to future generations.
It can also be a sense of wonder
about the world,
space and all that exists.
Or yes, the big idea could be
a belief in something bigger
than ourselves
that we can't quite fully understand,
but the presence of which we feel
from time to time.
The big idea, the intention,
and these three practices,
when coming together,
are extremely powerful
and are bigger
than the sum of their parts.
For me,
my big idea is that the Earth
is a goddess.
In Sanskrit, she is called Bhumi.
She is the life-giving source
that nourishes me and all that exists.
In order to sustain this idea,
I make sure I have a community
of people around me
who believe similarly.
Every morning, I have a simple ritual
where I offer her my worship,
thanking her for all that she provides.
And I try to show up in the world
with meaningful action,
treating her with the love, respect
and compassion that she deserves.
As we stand in this moment
of time together,
with all of the data
and science before us,
I believe we need to equip ourselves
with every tool and resource possible.
My invitation to all of us
is that we all find our big idea
and create communities,
rituals and practices
with renewed intention and purpose.
This framework not only has the potential
to help us build resiliency and momentum,
but it can profoundly transform the world.
It has worked for people and communities
for thousands of years,
and perhaps it could work for us now.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)